la ville de lyon est depuis ce matin en
quelque sorte la capitale européenne de
la lutte contre les virus les plus
dangereux qui menace l'humanité jacques
chirac inauguré aujourd'hui le premier
laboratoire européen de microbiologie
chargé donc d'étudier ces virus jusqu'à
présent seuls trois établissements
comparables exister dans le monde dont
deux aux états unis le labo fait de 4 et
comme protection et 4 pour désigner le
niveau de confinement requis pour
l'étude de ce virus ce labo est présenté
comme étant l'un des plus sûrs du monde
ce n'est le plus sûr du monde
oui ce laboratoire qui entrera en
fonction en avril prochain permettra
donc de contrôler et d'étudier les virus
mortel à commencer par ce débat est de
l'aca il permettra aussi d'identifier
rapidement les nouveaux virus est
potentiellement avait de données
l'alertent les scientifiques
travailleront dans des conditions
d'extrême sécurité reportage didier
guyot philippe évêques mesures de
sécurité exceptionnelles force des
vitres blindées code d'accès système
d'alarmé sas de décontamination
toutes les précautions ont été prises
seuls des chercheurs triés sur le volet
auront le droit de pénétrer sur 300
mètres carrés vont être étudiées les
virus les plus redoutables de la planète
les virus ebola lhassa mais aussi la
peste le choléra
ce laboratoire est un bunker c'est pas
simplement pour la prise d'otages mais
c'est effectivement une sécurisation
mécanique d'avoir des fenêtres cassables
d'avoir un blindage sur la périphérie
tout ça c'est ça me met à l'abri si vous
voulez de de l'accident simple stupid
suzanne fischer aut qui dirige ce
nouveau laboratoire depuis des années
elles traquent les virus en asie en
afrique elle se bat pour éradiquer ces
fléaux les microbes sont très
intelligents si nous trouvons une
solution
il s'adapte et nous présente un nouveau
problème alors nous serons toujours à
l'achat faiblir peut supporter d'autres
laboratoires de ce type existent mais
celui-ci le plus sophistiqué des équipes
du monde entier viendront ici étudié des
prélèvements vaincre la maladie c'est
beaucoup d'argent de la patience il y à
des échecs mais aussi des succès comme
les accents pour moi la science et au
service des patients
les patients qui existaient les patients
qu'on peut prévenir
c'est de prévenir les maladies alors
pour faire les vaccins les mettre sur
terre en selle et ça c'est l'objectif de
cette labo absolument faire la science
parce que simplement parce que ça fait
joli ça c'est rien coût de
l'investissement 50 millions de francs
entièrement financé par la fondation
mérieux un financement privé pour rendre
service au public
jean daniel